wait I have a question for
you um just because I was like a massive
fan girl of this show is it true that
you went to either audition or be part
of Dawson's Creek oh yeah what's that
tell me tell me tell man that's a real
positive spin on the real
story you were in Dawson's cre holy [__]
whoa it was either you or James
vanderby it came down to the wire D
that's how that's how like that's
whispered down the lane of I waited on
James Vander once and ate the rest of
his
hammer I believe that's the story in
variety you probably oh man no I went to
uh I flunked out of college uh in
1995 and the last thing I did in college
was uh I had a like a theater class and
the guy that taught it was really cool
and liked me and he said you know when
this unravels which I can tell that it
is uh there's a Repertory Theater in in
the area that you should audition to see
if you can go study there and I did and
my roommate at the time went to Chapel
Hill and he's like man there's there's a
real scene down there in uh in
Wilmington North Carolina because they
were filming Dawson's Creek down there
so instead of moving to New York or La
after graduating or after he moved to
[__] North Carolina to to make it in
show business you have one show that's
if they say
no I didn't and also I didn't know that
I didn't know understand the process
that just cuz they film it in North
Carolina doesn't mean they cast he was
just going to show up and like knock on
the door yeah I move here yeah I'm here
guys yeah and what came of that uh
nothing an an eight-month addiction to
crack cocaine and planting palm trees on
the beach in the burning North
Carolina really want to know that yeah
yeah you start sming crack
yeah yeah that's like the opposite of of
what to do I think because I any actors
struggling out there that's don't do
that I did I did I obviously I did blow
and down there that's what they did they
I mean you know there was like a version
of free basing or make it looked like
crack to me yeah you know what I mean it
was crack does that feel good oh it's
awesome yeah yeah it's all crack I never
didn't crack really no just meth meth
yeah yeah have you done crack what no
that's don't what you should have had a
piece of caviar when you slowly turn
your chair now you nose pimples have you
ever La types I tell you you don't like
movies or crack it's true what my mom
says about you guys see you don't like
crack do you you don't like movies you
don't like crack I KN I I knew something
about like everyone here I I'm starting
to feel like the minority because
everyone has done crack meth cocaine and
I've never done any of that uh no I've
you're not a nerd he likes an IPA I'll
tell you that I'm a I'm what they call
an
alol you like beer yeah I come from a
large drinking F that's great that's
great that's great and you know that's
wild too yeah it's pretty pretty crazy
it's crazy stuff like George ask him if
he's done crack have you done crack he's
on crack right now you never done crack
no just smoked cocaine you smoke cocaine
yeah okay that's in the family of in the
family of it yeah yeah was it in was it
in powder form or was it was it in a
rock form yeah you did Rock yeah yeah
and then what after 8 months of doing
that and planting palm trees I just I
was working as a landscaper and working
in the kitchen and Oh I thought that was
just something that you
did I got to start planting palm trees
pant Tre
time all right so you had a job doing
that oh yeah yeah I was living in like a
shitty uh apartment complex um and
working at a restaurant at a seafood
restaurant and working during the week
as a landscaper which was brutal wow
yeah wow wow but you still kept your
jobs no or did the crack get in the way
no crack never got in the way that's
crazy to be like